all right everybody i have a grift alert
for you today um this is i'm gonna give
you the facts that we know but i'm gonna
tell you ahead of time i've been looking
at this very strongly for the last 24 to
48 hours
my griftometer is going crazy right you
know how like with a geiger counter when
you get close to radiation it's like
it's going crazy
the equivalent of with griftiness
grifting
is going off in my head as if i were
next to the equivalent of a
uh
of uh exposed uranium with a geiger
counter
there is a new university being launched
with the help of former new york times
reporter barry weiss and others called
the university of austin
um
i'll describe it to you as it's being
reported okay the daily beast palantir
founder is backing barry weiss no degree
university
weiss is helping launch the university
of austin it is not yet accredited and
does not offer degrees okay so right
away you have to remember
part of why you go to university is to
learn
and part of why you go is because there
is this game it's admittedly it is a
game it's a system
in which you need this degree in order
to get certain jobs and so
maybe you would learn at this no degree
no accreditation university but it would
not exactly help you get a job
the former new york times opinion
columnist barry weiss known for her
diatribes against cancel culture
announced monday she's helping launch a
new university and it's universities in
quotes that will be quote dedicated to
the fearless pursuit of truth
the somewhat vague mission statement
suggests the institution called the
university of austin or uatx will be a
home for those who have been shunned
from quote illiberal college campuses
griped uatx's inaugural president pano
canelos four out of five american phd
students are willing to discriminate
against right-wing scholars
the announcement of this was posted to
barry weiss's sub stack newsletter which
you can sign up and pay for if you want
buried in the school's faq
it does not actually offer degrees nor
is it yet accredited
also noted in the faq the school is
fiscally sponsored by a little-known
non-profit called cicero research
according to public filing cicero is
affiliated with joe lonsdale co-founder
of the polarizing data mining company
palantir as of 2020 the non-profit
listed no assets lonsdale is also a
member of the uatx board of advisors a
spokesperson for the school said we're
very proud to have lonsdale on our board
and as a financial supporter
while less known than another palantir
co-founder the trump supporting
billionaire peter thiel lonsdale has
courted controversy he has sailed pete
but edge edge for taking paternity leave
uh any man in an important position who
takes six months of leave for a newborn
is a loser
in the old days men had babies and
worked harder to provide for their
future that's the correct masculine
response
the university of austin will launch
this summer offering forbidden courses
with provocative questions that often
lead to censorship
oh my god
um my griftometer is going crazy guys
it's going crazy a group of public
figures many of whom are vocal critics
of higher ed are launching a new
university reports bloomberg
the goal is to address a gaping chasm or
chasm between the promise and reality of
higher education
the board of advisors includes lonsdale
i've already mentioned that former
harvard university president larry
summers
former aclu president nadine strassen
david mamet neil ferguson who's been a
guest on this show i should mention
um glenn beck is really really excited
about this he read like a very strange
scripted thing on his show check this
out we are challenging a jealous
orthodoxy and expect to be scorned
mocked and viciously attacked
but with a healthy amount of courage
determination and yes money it can be
done right and when we succeed and look
back on this time we will see that it is
a small price to pay for all that we
have gained from the choice to be bold
today
right holy
cow
you know
we have been saying for a while
that the university system will collapse
on its own weight and that education is
going to have to change but it wasn't
going to do it before america collapsed
on her own weight without somebody
giving i mean the the histrionics and um
uh hyperbole here is just something else
some sort of
leadership
and and
another option i mean really
you're down to hillsdale
as the only university you could go to
this university
uh led by these people
is remarkable absolutely remarkable so
listen my griftomer is going off the
charts it really is i do want to say
there are people involved with this
project
that i don't think are bad people i mean
for example on the website one of the
founding faculty fellows is peter
bogosian who's been on this show a
number of times
uh he i think respects me as a leftist
who is willing to talk to people of
different views you know whatever
um i i think peter bruce is a good guy
and his intentions have always seemed on
the up and up to me although sometimes i
just don't disagree with his conclusions
about the degree to which
that this higher ed stuff
is actually the problem that he claims
it to be i have no problem with peter
burgosian in principle and he's involved
uh tyler cowan is an economist we've had
on the show i th he's involved he's
listed on the website i think a lot of
his economic instincts are excellent and
i know that he kind of i've seen some
shaky
cultural stuff from tyler cowan but for
the most part i like tyler cowan and i
think his economic thinking is
interesting jonathan height who's been a
guest on this program and i think has
great insights into a number of
different things
arthur brooks is involved arthur brooks
a conservative but the type of
conservative that i really enjoy
speaking with who's been a guest on this
program he's involved i had a very good
conversation with neil ferguson okay
fine why does it feel like a grift
um
the drama around
the
what i believe is a false belief
that academia at this point is just
worthless liberal trash
and that there needs to be something
like this which again not accredited for
now if that changes will let you know
doesn't even offer degrees
this just seems like something you can
pay for to get classes that might not be
that different
from the sub stacks of these people that
you can sign up for and so for now
calling this a university and saying
it's in any way an alternative to actual
universities
seems deceptive and like a complete and
total grift that's my view as of today
bearing in mind that there are people
involved with whom i don't have a
problem all right and if they want to
come and talk to me about it um i'm glad
to have them on that's no problem at all